[Musique]
ta peau contre map
merci d'être avec nous quitte à choquer
mais qu'est ce tu as qu amy winehouse
targonnais whaou en rien je me suis
habillée comme ça parce que on avait
l'impression que emmanuel macron
d'autres présidents frère pour nahla
qu'il est à punta cana
il avait un teint de ouf on l'a jamais
vue aussi frais depuis confinement il
était frais ils étaient tous vont animer
il est bronzé ou quoi il était bernard
montiel aux uv mois en voilà pendant ce
confinement
je vous le dis tout le monde s'improvise
tout et n'importe quoi alors tout le
monde s'improvise bricoleur ça veut dire
que maintenant tu as un problème il ya
des mecs qu'ils sont avec leurs neuf une
armoire qui te font refont une maison
broeckaert maintenant il n'a jamais
planté un clou pouf m et 1 1
un cadre amical au delà les mecs qui
sont à la ramasse tout le monde
s'improvise aussi mon frère tout le
monde sera promise cuisiner comme jenny
font tout et n'importe quoi
et au fond anosy au boucau sauf que mon
frère ça se transforme c'est un couscous
paella ça n'a rien à voir c'est
dégueulasse
voilà tout le monde fait tout et
n'importe quoi et il ya les mecs aussi
et les bugs qui s'improvisent coiffeurs
et coiffeuses et ça à ça à mon frère
parce que je le vois vous êtes à la
maison vous êtes avec votre mac os vote
9 et un moment il ya votre mug qui fait
tu sais que tu devrais peut-être
raccourcir un peu les côtés et là le mec
qui met ouais mais non je préfère
attendre la fin du confinement tout ça
mais tu veux pas que tu le fasses
franchement c'est rien du tout parce que
moi ta dont 2 je vais te le faire et là
tu sais très bien que le mec tu vas te
retrouver la meuf va commencer à dire ça
elle va monter là après elle va monter
là après va monter là mon frère tu te
retrouves sans déconner au bout de deux
jours tant philippe etchebest saad
connaît les traces ma totale arabesques
donc c'est une meuf donc j'estime qu'un
futur à l'arrière est plus long qu'est
ce qu'ils font dans arabesque y met un
mec
voilà et il le tue donc là le mec il est
mort donc là qui sait qui arrive c'est
pas le commissaire ont un truc ses
arabesques
c'est jessica pêcheurs tahri weight et
ce qui s'est passé me mets tout bas et
tout tu t'es quoi toi tu es romancière
ouais mais j'me mail web alors comment
ça se fait qu'il est mort tout ça mais
bon je veux mais je me mets je me mêle
et en fait ce qui se passe j'ai remarqué
dans plein d'épisodes d'arabesques c'est
que ai fait tout l'enquète voilà ils
sont comme ça parce que
un truc c'est comme hercule poirot elle
est réunie tous dans une pièce comme ça
et voilà
alors madame smith je vous ai vu vous
étiez à 14 ans au tennis
donc impossible que vous soyez à césar
avec un couteau en train de planter dans
monsieur jones donc voilà donc la halle
à rivel des toits 17h tu étais au
bowling donc c'est pas toi voilà lié
plus après le démon pas c'est toi c'est
mister banzaï
mr banzaï c'est pâques a tué un mister
jones et là elle fait tout l'anc est
hélas elles sont encaissées mister john
et à la mr godbout sort du placard
ma meilleure amie tous deux pointent
toujours tout à fait bienvenu je serai
toujours un peu
faye frère aussi c'est pareil alors il
file alors je sais pas si vous regardiez
x-files x-files t'arriver mon frère
c'est bon c'était une heure et demie tu
croyais que tu allais voir un fantôme
qui voyait rien tu entends des justes eu
[Musique]
toute la série mon frère et tu crois et
tu flippes et un thé chez toi tu es
comme ça t'as jamais rien vu la map est
arrivé à un stylo c'est un big tueur
dans mais sans déconner oui sauraient
ils sont et franchement ils ont tenu dix
saisons avec tous alors et maléfique et
simon s'entraîner je veux dire comment
ils vont s'entraîner mois dix mois déjà
ils vont s'entraîner en vo da parc mon
frérot comme michel drucker michel
drucker monter le col de l'alpe d'huez
année prochaine nous offrirons la michel
rocard et m a demandé de me prendre un
vélo dans la consultation payante star
trek j'étais pas comme un fou pour voir
l'autre il a des oreilles comme ça mon
frère c'est bon on dirait qu'il a deux
antennes là pour capter des deux flics
c'est voilà un oiseau fragile tout salon
mais c'est bon quoi l'autre spock de
quoi ce qu'il a fait ils sont à bord
d'un vaisseau alors star trek aussi
c'est le truc qui se passe rien quoi
camping paradis
c'est assez exceptionnel aussi camping
paradis
c'est la seule série frères queue pour
acheter une glace il tourne en temps
réel normalement dans un film quand tu
achètes une gas droite arié le mec qui
va il te montre pas eu dans camping
paradis ils veulent kahn est tellement
de minutes
ça veut dire tu as le mec qui fait qu'un
j'ai envie de manger une glace ah ouais
et banias marchand gas là-bas allons-y
le gaillard ils demandent la glace il
commande la glace vanille pistache tu
crois qu'il va se passer un truc tu
crois qu'il va avoir une attaque à la
glace entre lausanne en rien juste le
mec il a pris sa glace n'eurent pas ça
dure dix minutes ça veut dire que
camping paradis
mais le mec quand il juge sa voiture
c'est les seuls mecs dans camping
paradis ne sais pas si vous avez
remarqué pour gagner du temps ils
ouvrent pas comme ça avec le bip de loin
c'est le seul mec qui souvent genre à la
clé 100 électrique renault
[Musique]
animal implique c'est un mec jugeant qu
il avait tout et je loue le mec déjà le
héros déjà il a une tête me home mais
caprice des dieux on dire un fromage
avec toi déclarait-il à un peu une tête
est déjà celle où tu vois alors donc il
arrive et donc le mec il a un don ils
ont trouvé que ça c'est que le mec il
fait comme ça je me rappelle il est
comme ça et que ces lois et je vous
montrerai il mettait ses doigts comme ça
comme ça ils émettaient comme ça c'est
long il est comme ça et pouvait se
transformer en n'importe quel animal
mais lui le gars est pas et se
transformer en des animaux de ouf c'est
à dire le m il se concentre et de mousse
coma c'est tout tu croyais qu'il allait
transformer en panthère au guépard le
galilée kamal est là le gars il se
transforme en caux débris mon frère
c'était juste pour aller écouter une
chambre de la découpe des ses parents
comme par les avancées des trucs de ouf
dit va se transformer mon frère à ça
être un ours polaire rouge
[Musique]